the fastest way to accomplish any goal
is to model success
find someone who's already accomplished
what you're trying to do and put their
strategies to work for you
success leaves clues you just have to
follow them
otherwise you're gonna go and spend
countless hours and dollars in the wrong
direction and it's just gonna leave you
frustrated and angry
when i was in university i was one of
the top students in my class and meryl
lynch asked me to come and do a job
interview for a position in asia and
they wanted me to fly to new york
so they flew me out to new york and they
put me up in the waldorf astoria and i
remember sitting in this room full of
candidates
and i was nervous
i didn't want to talk to anybody i just
wanted to get into my interview and
start answering the questions i was
really nervous
the guy pulled me into the room and
i sat down and he started asking me the
usual questions
you know tell me about yourself what are
your goals
and then he asked me a question that
just stopped me cold
he asked me about what was happening in
the philippines and what impact would
have in the economy
and i had no idea
i don't even remember what i said i
stumbled on an answer but now i was
sweating
and i was embarrassed that i couldn't
answer these questions
he asked me another one and another one
and another one and again
i had no idea what to say i made
something up but it wasn't great
and i i now was panicking
i was scared that you know this wasn't
going to happen for me
and so a few more questions later he
showed me the door and said you know
thank me for your time
i come to new york with my girlfriend
and she was waiting for me and i came
down the elevators and went out the
front door the waldorf and i remember
seeing her face and she's got this big
smile on her face
waiting to hear the good news that i
would deliver
and i looked at her and all i could do
was
hang my head
because there was no way that i got that
job
and i didn't do well in the interview
because i was so distracted what i was
doing back home
i just joined this company and we're
trying to get it to go as a software
business and
whatever we did it seemed like we
couldn't make it work
we tried so many different things and
for whatever reason nothing was
happening we weren't getting momentum we
weren't getting customers and we thought
we're smart people we're you know we're
we we're trying to add value we
are working crazy number of hours to
make this thing go and it's just not
working
and i went to new york because that was
my backup plan i always thought
you know if i don't do well with this
business i can always go get a job and
so i was curious i didn't know if i'd
take the job or not but i wanted to at
least do the interview
well my backup plan disappeared there
was no backup plan i had to come up with
a new plan i had to make my business
work
and on the way back
something hit
i realized i'm not the first guy to try
to sell software before this can't be
that hard there's got to be something
i'm missing here
and so i looked at companies like
microsoft and mcafee into it and looked
at how they got started
i don't care how bill gates makes an
extra million dollars now but how do you
go from zero to one how do you go from
that idea to making his first million
dollars that was interesting for me
that's what i wanted to learn
and i realized i didn't have to be a
creative genius i'd have to come up with
everything myself i just had to model
success
so i researched those companies and
started putting those ideas to work for
our business
and it worked
and finally we had some momentum with
our company finally we had some
customers finally we had some traction
some energy going
and i just wish i'd figured this out a
long time ago i wouldn't have had to go
through all that crazy struggle and
frustration and anger that it takes to
start a business
if we just started on the right foot and
started modeling success from the
beginning
whatever challenge you're facing now
business or personal
somebody has already dealt with it and
done it in a fantastic way that can work
for you
success leaves clues
and if you model success
you can easily achieve your goals
good luck